well we know kyle freeland's ready to go
he sure loves pitching here he has that
bulldog mentality
that's a good start for kyle one out for
katel martade
got a fastball and hammers it down the
line it's in the corner martay picking
up where he left off last night patel
had a double in the first last night at
double in the first tonight a one-out
double ahead of his drupal cabrera swung
on and missed there's the second out
this is good it's a curveball right at
the bottom of the strike zone that's
basically a change up with a lot of
depth carson kelly at the plate with two
outs o2
he went and kyle freeland gets stride
off the field he struck out the side the
right-hander zach gallon the season
interrupted by injuries three different
times and it's been a struggle only one
win all year and that one was four
months ago
fastball right there for strike three
first down brendan rogers rocky's second
baseman
brendan rodgers that's a bullet up the
middle
and rogers just keeps on swinging the
back so here's charlie with brendan
rogers at first
charlie drives it to right
roger stops at second back to back one
out singles will bring up trevor story
gallant set and the 1-2
back to the slider gets a big strikeout
that's his second and now it's cj chrome
and that is a four-pitch walk to load
the bases
for ryan mcmahon
two outs two-two count and the pitch
he tried to check his swing at a
curveball he went around says edwin
moscow
and the inning is over gallon strikes
out the side but colorado
smith the lead off single here in the
second first baseman christian walker
here's the o2 on walker and
that's an excuse to swing this fourth
strikeout
already for freeland there the freedom
freaks a little synergy going on today
so two outs the second baseman drew
ellis there's a ground ball what a pick
by mcmahon on the short hop throws to
first to get ellis for out number three
mr smooth and silky
does it again he has had a gold glove
season in the infield and i certainly
hope he wins one now he'll face the
catcher elias diaz to start the colorado
second
got him four strikeouts for gallon went
back to that slider sam hilliard big
left hand battery
there's a swing and a miss from hilliard
and gallon now has five strikeouts he's
punched down for the last five rocky
everything right out there on the
outside corner of the plate to hillyard
that time see if he sticks with that
pattern in this ball game
swing and a miss gallon strikes out the
side in the second he's punched down
four in a row zach
kyle freeland's counterpart to lead off
the arizona half of the third gallon
strikes out
pretty quickly that's five strikeouts
first tie through for kyle freeland one
out and here's ahmed
got him
how pretty was that pitch kyle just had
nick ahmed basically like a yo-yo didn't
know what was coming with two outs
charlie blackman who saw one pitch
against zach gallon and lined it to
right
who lines that one into right field it's
a base hit
smith over to cut it off blackman
chugging for second here comes the throw
it is in time to get him haven smith
throws out charlie blackman trying to
stretch that one into a double and in
the inning yellen gets out of it with
some help from his right fielder fourth
inning as druva cabrera will lead off
this is middle of the diamond
storm a play by trevor story how good
was that notice how far trevor's having
to range kyle's like oh maybe i made a
bad decision nope let that guy take over
uses the dirt gets the bounce that is so
much range to his left what a play
braylon four innings of work so far has
thrown 11 pitches in an inning three
different times marshall leads off the
fifth
marshall sends one deep to left field
dalton varshall bounces one off the top
of the wall and gone dalton varshall
sends one out of here the diamondbacks
have a one-nothing lead
perfectly placed off the top of the
fence and over the seats that's a line
drive i didn't know if it was high
enough to get over the fence out there
just skimmed off the top one out ellis
at second
if kyle get the trifecta against the bed
swung on and missed he's got a bed for
the third straight time
seven strikeouts for freelance seven
strikeouts for zach allen tell marty a
double in the first he's one for two
ellis at second and two outs
sends one to center it drops in front of
hilliard out there ellis will score
and it's two-nothing diamondbacks i mean
martay from the right side of the plate
is without a doubt the hottest
diamondbacks hitter cattell just drives
it out there into right center field
hillyards floor to the plate
was way off line patel still over there
at first bottom five two-nothing d-backs
that gallon gets the bottom third of the
colorado order
that one hit in the air to center marte
going back still going back to the fence
reaches up and makes the catch it bangs
into the wall oh nice catch by catel
marte for the first out elias diaz
about as deep as you can go in this
ballpark and can tell martay
had just enough room sam hilliard to
strike out victims first time
there's another swing and a miss second
time tonight he's punched down hilliard
that's eight strikeouts for gallon and
two out to the fifth the pitcher kyle
freeland
look out zach that got him
cabrera recovers let's check on gallon
now just fine well there's your shutdown
inning one two three he's retired six in
a row that gallon one walk eight
strikeouts he'll face connor joe
zach gallon gets the swing and a miss
and that's strikeout number nine a lot
of breaking pitches that time to connor
joe starting with a curve ball through a
slider for the second pitch and then
finishes him off with another knuckle
curve in the dirt that time
blackman broken bat roller to first
walker has to wait for it underhands to
gallon who gets to the bag just ahead of
black bed gallon has now set down nine
in a row he's allowed just one base
runner since the first
two and two on ellis barshow at second
there it is straight through
eight punches for kyle freeland that is
a season high one out with gallon coming
up
there's strikeout number nine to god
for the fourth time tonight at the
golden subway for a mad
wonderful job of pitching by kyle
freeland the freaks love it struck out
10 for just the third time in his crib
this is the first base runner they've
had since the walk to cj krohn
in the first inning
fastball anthony's one and two right to
drew ellis and gallon gets a big double
play ball
that'll work too little number gallon
hustles over
and zach gallon gets three outs in the
seventh inning
and the diamondbacks have a two-nothing
lead and garrett hampson will pinch it
for tyler kinley and he drives one to
center field
high
deep
and out of here
touch him old time
garrett hampson
his second pinch homer of the year
the game is tied at two winning run at
second base with two outs diaz tonight
oh for two tenth pitch of the at-bat
coming
up drive deep left field this will get
it done and then
three run
walk off home run
elias diaz
touch him old time
elias diaz
in a 10 pitch at bat
walks it off
with a laser beam to left walk off win
number 12.
[Applause]